temos muitos médio
temos mais pacientes do que médico
quando a gente fica um pouco mais
experiente a gente começa a parar de
perguntar algumas coisas pacientes na
primeira coisa que a gente parar de
perguntar paciente como é que o paciente
está nem aí é porque a resposta dele é
sempre se estivesse bem não estava aqui
e ele começa a mudar essas perguntas
mudar se perguntar só que trouxe o
paciente a o nosso consultório do mesmo
jeito sendo oftalmologista gente para
demi divisão dos pacientes
no começo ele recebe pacientes logo
depois da cirurgia de catarata e começa
a querer ver no primeiro pós operatório
ele está enxergando aquele último
pontinho aquela última letrinha letra a
que está na última linha e ele não
enxerga o primeiro pós operatórios e
deixa todo mundo nervoso e depois o
tempo começa a mudar um pouco dessa
postura e começa a perguntar paciente só
se ele dormiu bem se está tudo bem com
eles que trouxe e lá ele está tendo
alguma a outra a sintomatologia
importante para a doença
esse tipo de mudança é uma coisa que vem
com a experiência ea gente começa a
ficar um pouco mais esperto nessas
interações esse mesmo paciente que vem
pra gente que a gente não pergunta como
é que ele está inicialmente ele vem
falando que mudou alguma coisa
importante na vida dele e nós acabamos
abrindo os olhos desse paciente e eu
acabei chamando essa conversa que eu
estou tendo aqui com vocês de abrolhos
que exatamente está aqui né é
arquipélago de abrolhos que é no sul da
bahia e aparentemente os portugueses
deram esse nome porque precisava abrir
os olhos pra que um sinal fraga's inês
arquipélagos
a mudança de rota que nós conseguimos
fazer alguma coisa nova conseguisse
transformar o nosso caminho inicialmente
e tem a ver com isso a conversa toda a
catarata voltando um pouco ao lado do
técnico aproveitando deve ser unifesp
ela é uma afecção onde o cristalino que
além de está dentro da gente fica
inicialmente deformada
depois ela fica amarelada a pessoa fica
branca e aí a gente não enxerga mais
nada
hoje em dia com o avanço tecnológico a
gente começa a operar os pacientes antes
eles não enxergarem mais nada já começa
a enxergar a operar os pacientes quando
eles não começam a enxergar amarelado
contrário já não é tão boa qualidade de
vida dele piora
isso é o que eu tenha tratado aqui no
money e tomou nenhum teve a catarata
deliberada ele consegue retratar um
jeito lindo como ele enxergava o mundo
amarelado e depois ele passou a enxergar
o mundo azulado que o mundo mais branco
isso é uma modificação cerebral que não
é tão óbvia é uma modificação cerebral
para a qual a gente não está preparado
nem como médico eo paciente
provavelmente não está preparado também
catar ainda é um problema bastante
importante no nosso meio
você chegando aqui vira um multirão aqui
nem do departamento de oftalmologia
dando óculos para as crianças essa é a
primeira causa de cegueira reversível no
mundo infelizmente a segunda catarata
então a gente ainda faz esse tipo de
mutirões esse é o primeiro mutirão que
departamento de oftalmologia aqui da
escola paulista de medicina da unifesp
fez em manaus ainda são feitos mutirões
os pacientes voltam a enxergar a gente
abre o olho nos olhos dos pacientes
isso vai provavelmente continuar sendo
feito por algum tempo que vai ter que
ser feito por mais tempo e melhor é a
preparação dos médicos que operam esses
pacientes
como é que a gente educa esse pessoal
como é que a gente muda a cabeça das
pessoas para que as pessoas consigam
sentir neles mesmos a mudança e passar a
mudança adiante
então essa é a função do educador
entender inicialmente como se faz e se
repaginar momento essa repaginação essa
a reconexão esse rio aire dos filhos
todos para que entendendo isso
internamente a gente consiga se
prontificar a mudar nos entendendo
sabendo que já está mudando é nosso não
é do outro e mudar o outro eventualmente
aí é o pai na cor é o ápice ao sangue é
tudo que a gente quer conseguir mudar os
outros então como é que a gente consegue
fazer isso podemos fazer isso via exame
de imagem e eu voltei aqui uma
ressonância magnética de um dos gênios
que eu conheço vou falar isso não mais
tarde um pouquinho
ramesh raskar podemos fazer com testes
bobo de personalidade está aqui um teste
que fiz no museu da manhã dizendo que eu
sou o comandante desconfiado e eu acho
que ele tem que fazer isso mais
ativamente eu sou um incentivador e um
chato dizendo que todos os estudantes
que mexem com gente deveriam ser
analisados antes no sentido de que
terapia não terapêutica terapia deveria
ser uma disciplina obrigatória não ele
não eletiva dentro do currículo médico
todo estudante deverá fazer terapia para
se conhecer
na hora que você se conhece você pode
eventualmente escolher mudar ou não
mudar e mudar os outros
a gente não faz isso a gente só coloca
os do primeiro ano e vão que vão até o
sexto ano mas o conhecimento interno
conhecer de dentro para fora e parece
ser muito mais efetivo importante do que
o conhecimento externo
algumas experiências que virar
iniciativas e que estão incorporadas ao
currículo fazem parte desse tipo de
pensamento de dentro pra fora
como é que a gente consegue a atenção
dos estudantes hoje no que vocês chamam
de geração milénio geração y importa e
que me parece ser uma geração que
precisa se concentrar um pouco mais
rapidamente e não se concentra só por
persistência se concentra porque existe
pertinência no que você está falando pra
ele conheça a pertinência para alguma
coisa que a gente botou uma fotografia e
isso a gente faz até hoje coloca uma
foto independente qualquer fotografia e
começa a perguntar para os pacientes
qual é o nome desse paciente
eles não entendem isso como a ser
fotografada irmãos e têm como é que se
chama esse paciente eles começam a
entrar nessa história os pacientes se
chama antonio de jesus está bom a j&j
quando escrevi a história escreveu j o
quanto ele tem a j 32 anos assim como
essa para a história porque ele tem 32
anos
ele tem 32 anos porque lá a conjuntiva
dele não tem dobra a conjuntiva de que é
mais velho tem dobra e aí começa a
prestar atenção e começam a falar mais
coisas você começa a perguntar e eles
fazem aqueles duração dos fãs do
paciente a história da mulher atual
a gente começa a perguntar qual é quais
são os dados do exame físico que ele
espera desse paciente alguém espera que
esse paciente
que tem a visão baixa não ninguém espera
por quê porque ele tem uma hemorragia
subconjuntival nossa você está pensando
nisso tô
então tá bom vamos por esse caminho
vamos discutir um rádio subconjuntival e
de uma hora para outra você tem as
pessoas com uma pergunta pertinente indo
atrás da resposta que lhes interessa e
todo mundo concentrado indo na mesma
direção e isso é uma das propostas que a
gente entende que mudam dar pertinência
ao que se faz isso na novidade já se faz
em pbl chamou isso aqui de aprendizado
baseado em vivência uma experimentação e
isso desemboca numa outra atividade que
a gente também fez que atividades de
oficinas de inovação e essas oficinas
hoje capitaneados por esse grupo cimed
hacker
são lugares aonde se tem temas
relevantes e importantes pertinentes
discutidos ea oportunidade de se fazer
modificação em materiais comuns para
prototipar algumas soluções para aqueles
problemas parece relativamente difícil
de falar é muito fácil de fazer tão
juntas estudantes fundamentalmente de
engenharia de computação design com
médicos enfermeiros odontólogos e quem
mais vocês quiserem com problemas que
existem e cimpor dera esses estudantes
para mudar aquela realidade eu aprendi a
fazer isso na índia com aquela
tomografia
o dono da tomografia com ramesh raskar
foi lá e fez isso junto com a equipe de
marketing onde em cinco dias foram
desenvolvidos 25 protótipos funcionais
em oftalmologia voltando pra cá com
apoio do ministério na época fizemos
duas grandes oficinas em são paulo uma
de saúde do idoso e uma outra relação
médico-paciente uma com crianças do
ensino fundamental foi maravilhosa que
chamava olhando para dentro do corpo
nós estávamos nos kits pré formados para
essas crianças que em duas horas faziam
aparelhos da cabeça deles mas da
imaginação deles para olhar para uma
parte do corpo fizemos uma com pós
graduandos aqui da escola e muito mais
interessante do que isso a gente
conseguiu em poder a um grupo de
estudantes do colégio a escola a do
ensino médio para fazer isso por
eles então na primeira figura até tô na
segunda figura já não estou mais
isso virou uma disciplina curricular do
ensino médio o ensino baseado em
transformação e isso muda a cabeça das
pessoas estão envolvidas nisso e isso
acaba desaguando uma mudança tecnológica
da sociedade
então pega uma pergunta pertinente em
poder às pessoas e dá pra elas alguma a
solução para ser desenvolvido
isso tem a ver fundamentalmente com
gente né isso tem a ver com um choque de
pessoas
então uma pessoa se choca com a outra
pessoa se choca com o mesmo de produzir
energias estão relativamente acostumados
a ouvir isso
na hora que ele fala de física então um
átomo se choca com o outro e produz
energia e indo pegar essa metáfora da
física se atos parecidos se chocam com
os mesmos átomos
a gente produz uma coisa que é muito
boba que é unidirecional que
monocromática que é uma fase só chama
laser superútil bobo
o que é legal legal é quando átomos de
moléculas diferentes se chocam e produz
luz produzir uma coisa que ilumina que
irradia e quanto mais melhor
então essa é a pegada do med hacker é
juntar gente diferente disciplina e nós
não acreditamos mais indisciplina isso
parece ser uma coisa moderna
nós temos chamado esse grupo de
indisciplinar não é indisciplinado em
disciplinar tem disciplina que junta
todo mundo e esse grupo produz soluções
em poderá pessoas educa e nova sem se
preocupar com patente porque patente na
nossa visão é alguma coisa muito
importante para se manter o conhecimento
não para amplificar o conhecimento na
época que acreditar e continuar fazendo
essas oficinas nada daqui a duas semanas
vai ter uma das oficinas em são carlos
que já está aqui se chama triagem visual
já tem inscritos e das mais diversas
matizes de artistas historiadores
designers médicos engenheiros arquitetos
todo mundo e empresas interessadas em
pegar essa tecnologia e levar à frente
nesse nessa dominação a mundial de
muitos eu acabei caindo no lugar comum
onde todo mundo que fala de muito acaba
voltando que é a tal da internet
especificamente no lugar que eu descobri
que foi minha última descoberta um mês
atrás que chama facebook fez todos
conhecem o facebook mas eu fui conhecer
o facebook por dentro então se o
facebook mesmo léo tem uma bandeira de
pirata em uma cafeteria do facebook tem
um lugar que eles guardam bicicleta e
tem esse cara que é o tal do ramesh
raskar que está fazendo um ano sabático
dele dentro do facebook me puxou pra lá
e eu coloco isso aqui dizendo que eu não
acreditava muito nessa história de mídia
social achava que não era um instrumento
importante para educar as pessoas e eu
estava completamente errado estava
completamente errado e que me provou
isso foi um dos posts que eu fiz que eu
comecei a escrever na internet no
facebook em algumas revistas que deu uma
repercussão enorme que mexeu de dentro
pra fora com as pessoas e isso esse
ponto diz mais ou menos isso
então se vocês quiserem virar de ponta
cabeça e não consegui enxergar isso bem
senão vocês vão ver que isso aqui é um
cirurgião um fazendo cirurgias de
catarata é um cirurgião extremamente
hábil competente r muito amigo que fez
12 cirurgias de catarata em uma hora à
cirurgia em si é rápida mas a troca de
pacientes têm que ser a jato
isso acabou sendo um mote e ainda é um
mote para os novos cirurgiões
eu comecei a conversar com você dizendo
que a gente aprende coisas ao longo da
vida a ensinar ou ter como modelo de uma
catarata tem que ser feito em quatro a
cinco minutos para um residente
recém-formado é um grande desserviço que
nós mesmos estamos fazendo para as
gerações que vem e eu percebi isso na
pele o que porque sendo o chefe do
departamento de tecnologia eu comecei a
ser demandado por kits que fazem
cirurgias de vitrectomia ea palavra
vitrectomia se ver sozinha é legal
se vier junto com catarata não é legal a
vitrectomia catarata significa
a tata complicou e começar a perder
muito kit de vitrectomia e os
orientadores começaram a dizer paulo
deve estar complicando um pouco a
cirurgia e não foi muito difícil juntar
é concreto é bom seja está operando
desse jeito não dá para operar em quatro
minutos você é recém formado
você começa a operar em quatro minutos
depois e tem um tempo grande de
informação e esse post foi colocado com
essa a tendência na internet teve uma
repercussão enorme de todo mundo fala
nossa eu achei que eu tinha duas mãos
esquerdas e que eu era um horrível o fim
da raça humana porque opera em 15
minutos e opera em 20 minutos está
perfeito nesse posto acabou dizendo que
as cirurgias de catarata departamento
deverão durar pelo menos 17 minutos
isso fez um sucesso estrondoso isso muda
o paradigma isso mudou a cabeça das
pessoas
onde eu quero chegar com essa história
toda quero chegar no ponto do educador
transformador
nós somos e devemos formar agentes de
transformação aparece um papinho
mas se a gente não tiver na cabeça que a
sociedade a ser transformada depende de
educadores transformados
nós vamos transformar nada então dar a
mesma educação da mesma forma e esperar
que em qualquer outro resultado não
preciso dizer para vocês que é esse tipo
de apresentação que é muito mais moderno
do que todos os outros que é menor
a gente consegue continuar prestando
atenção e agente prepare as
apresentações é um avanço enorme podemos
avançar muito mais
a gente tem que ir mudando está aberta a
mudança internamente nos conhecer fazer
com que o outro entenda a mudança para
que ele possa mudar também
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]